um like to turn the subcommittee's
attention to Amendment um 0981 H which
is the one that was just passed around
this was the official language that we
talked about the last time we met on
this bill did have an opportunity to
look into the one concern that I had
mentioned and it's fine so um I I feel
comfortable with that um so once again
line 12 C um just defines station Weare
uh which wasn't defined before hi
Peter um which wasn't defined
before um makes the um requirement that
the manufacturer tells us whether or not
past is in the material later on um and
then on the back side uh one thing that
was was changed from what we talked
about on page two line nine uh that
paragraph should a safe alternative to
the current firefighting personel
protective equipment be designed and
manufactured fire departments may give
preference to that it was should but
nobody really cares all that much that
I've talked to out here um because
really the meat of the bill is below
that um in sections six beginning
January 1st 2025 uh fire department
shall not provide as an option the
purchasing of that station Fireware and
then um on July 1st 2025 fire department
shall not provide as an option the
wearing of the same so that just um
addresses a representative Le's concern
about downshifting cost it gives them
time to get their allowance and then
time to go out and make the purchase um
so that they can transition away from uh
the PC lated stuff to safer Alternatives
so that once again was just kind of the
synopsis on the amendment that we talked
about last time we just didn't have it
officially so subcommittee wants to just
take a couple minutes to look at it or
if you feel comfortable with it you can
let me
know okay
this this is the language we've we've
been talking about so so it's just a
question of having it physically so now
we can vote on it yeah and of course we
got some people here this morning I look
over there and uh people some people
have not been here before maybe mostly
all of you I'm not sure but we certainly
want to hear from them whether whether
their issues and especially represented
pu who himself is a is a longtime uh for
he's a former member of Edna Asin know
um and uh very involved in this type of
situation that's why he's here this
morning yeah I no he's here for the next
one actually because the next one's his
bill but he can speak on this one if
you'd like as well um but anyway yes I
just wanted to hear from the committee
first if you had any concerns with the
language and then I'll open up to
anybody out here who' like to speak on
this if there are any concerns with the
language if you've been able to see the
language everybody's comfortable with
that very good um with that then I'm
comfortable with it if the committee is
comfortable with it I'm willing to
entertain a motion from the
subcommittee you're just about I I'm
happy to make the motion ought to pass
with Amendment yeah you know on the
amendment on the amendment right yeah
yeah okay um we'll just all in favor on
the amendment on the amendment and then
I move pass with Amendment second Brad
second all in
favor awesome great guys it was that
easy you're
welcome and I don't know who's here
everybody might be here for 1079 give me
a second to fill out the paperwork and
then we'll move on to 1079 if you uh
want to remind yourselves that I handed
out um representative PR's amendment to
1079 which is five pages long if you
guys want to just kind of take a glance
at that while I'm filling with the
paperwork you
talking you are speaking about 333 right
uh yes 333 H yep
okay
welcome back would you like to join
us I have one if you think if can
you welcome back to
Ed hi nice to be
back um so uh when we had the original
public hearing on it we didn't really go
into any form of detail on the amendment
that uh you were presenting if I
remember correctly um so I just kind of
wanted to give you the opportunity to
kind of present that Amendment and give
us the highlights as you see them and so
we were trying to
include more emergency
responders um one of the groups I was
looking at is the emergency room
Personnel in hospitals as we they've
requested our services quite a bit
lately and when we were doing that we
did decided to go with the
definition that the feds use for
emergency responders cuz they kind of
change it from time to time add delete
so that way we wouldn't have to keep
coming back to this to change it to add
or
delete we can just float along with
them is what we were looking to do uh
real quickly represent a so where is
that found if you want to attach it to
the federal definition so in the
Highlight behavioral emergency response
Public Safety workers oh wait a
minute if you give us a page in line
number that'd be
helpful
yep
sorry plan on being here
early that didn't work
out
because I didn't I didn't see a federal
no in there there's a couple of rsas but
yep hang on I'll get
there so one of the things that we did
page two line 21 hospital emergency
Personnel mean staff rendering care
rescue support life samic while in an
emergency
department so it includes anybody that
would have come into contact with that
patient at that time
um you want to come
up I'm gonna bring Justin yeah please
join us he helped it's pretty it's a
subcommittee meeting it's pretty
informal good morning gentlemen just
some of you are very familiar faces I
appreciate the time with you this
morning for those of you that I have not
had the pleasure to meet my name is
Justin Bretton I am the mental health
and wellness cour coordinator at the
Manchester Police Department I am the
coordinator for our Southern New
Hampshire critical incident stress
management team uh and the members that
you see behind me are some of the best
peer supporters that we have in the
state um so we're very fortunate to have
this time with you and and happy to
answer all these questions um what Mr PR
if I can draw your attention to line 20
uh which page sorry on the second page
okay um is where we start to talk about
the addition of Emergency Department
Personnel um it's it's important that we
Define that as representative CR said um
and I'm just looking for you we do that
um and we utilize the language if if we
could just clarify on the copy that we
have line 20 you said on page two just
says state city town or private
Emergency Services level sorry 21 okay
you're the hospital emergency Personnel
yes sir okay
yep so that is where we start to define
those additional individuals that we're
looking to support um as representative
pu said that's come from a direct
request from the hospitals for that
support sure uh the men and women in
those departments see what we bring in
trauma and Devastation to them on a
daily basis um and they're left to try
to help not only law enforcement put the
pieces back together but the men and
women in the communities that we serve
they're serving our families as well um
and when we bring them those individuals
expose them to critical incidents
they're often Lo left unsupported um and
that is one of the genuine intent of the
this change is to make sure that those
folks have the support that they need
after they're exposed to that trauma
okay one of the bigger one of the other
aspects that we were hoping to to
utilize to bolster the statute um was to
help address the underserved retired
population of the law enforcement
Community um I don't know how much
historical knowledge you gentlemen have
of this statute but we were fortunate in
the state of New Hampshire to have it
passed in
2013 um this has been a tool that we
have utilized across the state in all
assets of first the first responder
Community to really break down the
stigma and barriers that exist to
accessing appropriate culturally
competent mental health support services
across the state um when we wrote the
statute one of the biggest oversights
was the need to not only retain our
retired Personnel on our teams but also
to make sure sure that our retired
Personnel had access to support services
well after they left our profession um
you gentlemen might have heard a lot of
talk throughout the state house this
year about the Recruitment and Retention
issues amongst the first responder
Community um and but being able to
retain our retired members on our teams
as well as provide services to them will
absolutely be a tool that we can utilize
to help mitigate some of those
Recruitment and Retention issues
question on that one so page two line 28
I see where the retired where we add
retired to members of the critical
incident stress management team yes sir
where are we adding the
services so in that those Services
provided to retirees would come in um
under any individuals receiving services
so we have bolstered that section it it
already stated that the individuals
receiving Services uh were confidential
and protected by the confidentiality
statute as well um but we further
expanded that with a more clearly uh
outlined uh definition or not definition
but more clearly outlined language sure
where where is that um what page and
line number so we can take a look at for
one moment sir yep no rush so that is
going to be on page three and it starts
on line four nor any
person okay so you're looking to nor any
person to include retired people correct
sir you didn't want to specify that more
clearly because we can I mean we have
time to make changes if if the
subcommittee feels that that would help
answer any and all doubt or speculation
in the future I absolutely think now is
the time to do that yeah well I'll make
a note of it anyway so we can discuss
yeah Peter did you want to say something
thank you very much Mr chairman so going
back to page two
uh I have a an issue with the fact that
line 22 said while in the hospital
emergency department
so uh how about if they're outside uh or
they get called out somehow it seems to
me that the the while in is is not the
central
aspect uh the the thing is are they are
they attached to the hospital emergency
department that's that's their
employment that's their uh that that's
their assignment and so forth whether
they're actually physically in the
department I think I think is irrelevant
if that that's their normal place and
they are attached to the hospital and
emergency department either full-time or
part-time or whatever and and so if
they're if they're away called out uh
across a block across the street
whatever they are part of the it's the
fact that that that they're exposed to
this type of uh work environment that is
so stressful that so that's and and I'm
okay with expanding that but yeah before
before your answer representative just
want a clarification sorry um yeah I
think the difficulty um representative
Schmidt in this from my perspective is
we're looking to make sure that anybody
who's in the space when it happens has
access to the care they may or may not
be an actual employee correct well we
could have like a respiratory Tech come
down from the floor X-ray tech come in
right so they're in that space that's
not their
official uh area to work is the
emergency room it it's just they come
because it's a big emergency so you
could get a nurse from the uh ICU come
down to help them so if they're in that
space working um that's fine but I also
see representative Schmidt's um idea is
sometimes they'll take a a nurse from
the emergency department stick them in
the ambulance for a critical
transport to another hospital or
something like that right but I would
think that because they came up out of
the emergency room with that patient
they should be covered but you know well
but you're you're also raising a
complete different point and that is you
got somebody who is not ordinarily
attached to the emergency department but
that day they're there and they're
exposed to that traumatic
experience and maybe it's only one time
thing
but if it's bad enough one time is
enough you're in there and you're seeing
something God awful then you've been
traumatized
so I you're you're covering something of
a different aspect but I think both
things are equally valid that was the
point that I was turning to out I think
you got to be careful what you do with
the language because you don't want to
negate the one by adding the other
representative boy did you want to say
something thought is exposure I mean you
could have civilian Personnel that
happen to be in there with one of their
family members and they have to see this
right as they're being rolled into the
emergency room
and and and of course the other
component to this that I think we'll
have to keep in mind and try to keep
balance whatever we decide to do in work
on is this is a peer support network as
well correct so I mean you you aren't
licensed in the same way as a licensed
mental health professional right so we
got be a little careful we have specific
training and and we have to be trained
to fit into this guideline right so I
mean the family member may not fit into
this because they're not a here there is
a actually a a a debar team that does
civilians and that's their job and
they're run by the state and we refer
them to that or the mental health
catchment in their area okay that's good
to know any other questions at this
point all right if you want to continue
and and just for some clarification for
representative Schmidt um we we hope our
genuine intent of covering all those
people is very clearly defined uh on
page two line 21 uh under sub paragraph
number I uh is where it says Hospital
Emergency Department Personnel means
staff rendering care so the genuine
intent there is to capture all of those
individuals that you're concerned about
um and so I I do hope that we adequately
address that for you in that language
well we do but but I mean representative
pu has has pointed out why it says while
in because if they're there whether
they're ordinarily attached to but if
they're there in that on that day at
that time and expose that
trauma yes sir then we need to we need
to protect them
too thank you any other things that
you'd like to highlight from the bill
because I'd like to at some point too go
kind of through line by line and just
address a couple of thoughts I had but
um yeah absolutely I just will before we
move on I would like to make sure to
fully answer your question is that we
are it is correct we are not licensed
but we are trained peer supporters and
certified by the international critical
incident Foundation to offer these
Services the delivery the supports that
we're offering are not clinical in
nature we are trained to recognize the
normal reactions to stress and Trauma
we're trained to educate our peers on
what those are normalize those reactions
and the biggest component of our peer
support network is to make sure that
we're able to refer out to culturally
competent licensed providers when those
needs arise we are genuinely the bridge
to those support services that are
usually very difficult for our Personnel
to access because of the stigma that
surrounds First Responders reaching out
for help so our genuine mission is to
make sure that we break down those
barriers and we are able to connect our
peers to those licensed providers to get
the support that they need right my main
concern was because it is peer driven is
there liability if you step outside the
scope in some way so if we've gone
beyond peer to somebody else are you at
all liable for offering services to
somebody who according to the um what
was it the IC ISF um ICF yeah that um
has basically so given us your scope of
practice for lack of a better way of
putting it scope of practice but it's
also the train if you could use the mic
represent sorry sorry it's also the
training right if if you stay in that
model you should be somewhat protected
what happens is the confidentiality
falls off if it's not one of those
gotcha members okay so and that's what
we're looking for is to make sure we can
provide services to to the people Mo and
we only really seek out First Responders
right um but they come in many sizes and
shapes ski patrol the mountain rescue
people uh wide area sometimes you you
think oh yeah I all forgot all about
those guys um but we want to make sure
we have that confidentiality right
because like he said the stigma is still
there right and we want to make sure uh
and not maybe not so much in the Fire
EMS side but I know on the police side
uh it's always been a concern
that if my boss finds out what will
happen to my job right and more and more
that stigma and that whole thing is
going away but it's still in the back of
a lot of Minds so they want want to be
sure that when they seek these Services
what set in the room stays in the room
right so and that's what we're trying to
make sure happens is
that they can
come in confidence know that what said
in the room stays in the room and and
and when they we send them off to uh a
mental health professional that follows
them right so that's our big thing about
this
okay for members of the committee is
everybody pretty
well um feel comfortable with the intent
of the material what we're trying to
accomplish all right so having said that
I think we we get the concept and I
think for the most part it seems like
we're pretty much in support of the
concept um just like to get into the
specifics of the actual Amendment which
would become law to make sure that we
know what we're doing and what we're
recommending and um so if I may on page
one
line8 um
we start to see the term so we've we've
crossed out emergency service provider
as a result of response to the incident
and we've replaced it with emergency
response SLU safety worker we're going
to use that several times um so that
term I see that it's used and and the
meaning of it can be inferred at the top
of page two in that first paragraph par
paragraph F the meaning of that term can
be inferred from there is that defined
anywhere in statute though or should we
be defining that and statute because
it's it's referenced so much in this if
we don't know what it is
then thank you sir very good question so
that title uh came from a direct result
of our commission to study incidents of
PTSD amongst First Responders uh there
is a sub there's a committee that's
formed legislatively mandated and in
place where there are representatives
from the first responder community that
come together on a monthly basis to look
into how we can better support our First
Responders there's members of your
subcommittee on that that panel with us
um we worked very hard to create some
additional supports um for families and
survivors of suicide um and that term
and definition comes directly from some
work that we did within the workers
compensation statute which is
281a um and so that title comes
specifically from that language to make
sure that the definition of First
Responders is accurate accurately
represented throughout statutes across
the state uh I think it's important to
make sure that we meet nearer existing
language in other places and so the
language proposal that you see there is
a means to try to clean up our statutes
across the board when it comes to
dealing with issues revolving around
First Responders okay
so let me just
um
oops all right so
281 so
281a
correct believe that's the worker
workers compens that's workers
compensation yes sir so do you know what
part underneath
that really testing my memory sir I've
got the list if you want to look at it
17 maybe I've got the list if you want
to look at it
thank you yep incident y 17 incident of
post-traumatic stress so that that's our
that's our peer support statute so RSA
281 d a semic 177e and then a VC is
where emergency response and Public
Safety workers are
defined
correct
yes so if you follow on on page two one
one second I'm so sorry so 281 a17 and
then you said Roman numeral 5 nope sir
so uh 281a yeah two and it falls under
subsection v-
C2
all right maybe I'm just open
up
when did you put it that was done in
last legislative session maybe
it's that could be the I was like
there's not one here if I take this not
at
all just not up yeah be next oh okay I'm
not going crazy it's just not there yet
all right so um emergency response
Public Safety worker means call
volunteer or regular firefighters law
enforcement officer certified under RSA
106l certified County Corrections
Officers emergency communication
dispatchers and rescue or ambulance
workers including Ambulance Service
emergency medical personnel first
responder service and um volunteer
personnel and that matches
what you did in on page two in the first
paragraph Y and you you see that we
added uh hospital emergency personel uh
Corrections Sheriff's um deputy sheriff
State Police civilian law enforcement
civilian County
Corrections and then it goes into the
volunteer reg okay so I mean and the
members of the subcommittee can jump in
if you have thoughts on this um if
you're going to use this and you want to
keep it consistent then shouldn't we
either amend RSA 281 to include these
things or so the one issue with doing
that is you're going to a if you're
going to look to add the emergency um
Hospital staff to that you're going to
open up the whole workers comp statute
to adding those people and including
those people within those benefits um
because that's where that that's what
that statute specifically addresses the
the compensation and support that's
available to those First Responders uh
during workers comp claims so that would
be I believe a whole another discussion
of whether or not those people are
eligible those individuals are eligible
for those supports through that statute
it seemed a little bit out of the scope
of what we were trying to yeah no I I
agree with you the concern that I have
primarily is you said that you wanted to
keep it for consistency across the rsas
but this isn't going to be consistent
across the rsas because you're Chang
if if we keep this as the standard which
it's not really L it's not in this
section of the rsas right s workman's
compensation in the rsas um you're
including more people than just the
people in the emergency response Public
Safety worker over here so my my concern
is and my question is should we be
putting a definition into this
section that defines emergency response
Public Safety worker and includes the
people that you want it to include so in
that
commission it was all about a lot of it
was about work workman's comp they had
uh people for primax and labor and stuff
so for whatever reason they didn't want
to include them in that section in the
workers comp but we want to include them
in
our offering right so we added that
on top of that right and my question is
and Peter you might you might know
better than I should dur instead of
doing it here in the first paragraph on
page two when we're dealing with
definitions on page one should we have a
definition section that says emergency
response Public Safety worker for the
purposes of this
subdivision um emergency response Public
Safety worker shall include any law
enforcement officer roll them out so
that it's defined in the statute and
then when we get to paragraph two or
paragraph one on page two you don't have
to list them again you can just refer to
the definition that we've already laid
out and that way if it comes up again
you can just refer back to the
definition because as it stands at this
point if you want to make change in the
future or something else happened you're
going to have to go back and change
every other place that listed change the
definition next time does that make
sense to people okay sure because it's
not it's not the same as you have it
listed so you want to take that
paragraph and pretty much make it a
definition I want to I want to take that
paragraph make it a definition in the
first section under definitions and then
when you get to this section you can
literally just say critical incident
stress management team member oh and by
the way is that supposed to be team
member or team
member on online one team members twice
is it supposed to be there twice it
doesn't seem like it is
oh
yeah strike one of those so plur team
member or team members plural okay make
it team members okay fix
that um so yeah the paragraph would say
critical incident stress management team
member or team members
means um an emergency response Public
Safety worker specially trained to
provide critical incident stress
management and crisis intervention
services as a member of an organized
organized and registered team so makes
sense yes sir that that does make sense
okay especially if we clearly Define
that on page one and this is essentially
the definition that you're looking for
correct yes sir okay very good anything
from the committee yes representative
Schmid thank you Mr chairman so it
occurs to me that uh that we're getting
into a situation where we've got this is
all useful I'm not uh you know trying to
downgrade it whatsoever but what we're
doing is we're creating a
category that's got that's got a a long
T tail right so and and these people are
in that category do we want to create
some kind of an acronym because
otherwise we've got half a paragraph
Just defining the people or naming the
people I should say def definition is
important because everybody and these
people are they're regular members so
there
are acronyms out there like EMT we don't
have to say emergeny management we know
EMT it's a Trope it's a so once once we
Define this on page one then we can just
use critical
cism team member okay it's just I'm
raising the issue because to the degree
that we have a long
Y and it becomes awkward because and I
think unfortunately it has to be a long
tail because if you don't Define them
then somebody will come along and say
they're not
covered they don't get the
confidentiality they don't get the
services and if you gave them Services
now we can hear what we have to know
what they said and and we can compel you
I I I I I get it and I'm not quarreling
with that at all the thing is if you got
it's just like this committee is called
Edna because otherwise if we said
executive departments an administration
every time we'd be halfway through the
day before we got the name of the
committee out there my family still have
we got something that we
can right abbreviate cism team member
okay even that is a bunch of words
team member no no that's too few what
I'm looking for is an acronym because
then you've got something that becomes
people think this person is
a CSM I'm only raising the issue I'm not
saying I can't support this because
there's just too damn many words
here give that some thought guys
um okay so so that would take care of my
first concern what was making sure that
that was defined so that we had a a
workable definition for what exactly it
was that we were talking
about
thought and other people can take the
mic if they'd like to share I mean you
guys can switch out a little bit you
know absolutely so I
think instead ofstead of second person
we can get it first person we just
wanted to clarify to get back to where
the some of the initial language came
from which might help explain why we
were trying to mirror the existing
language into yeah know I understand the
the it's good to mirror the language I
just want to make sure that you know
we're clearly defining what we're
talking about here
yes good morning uh my name is Bill
ainson I'm the recently retired
assistant fire chief in NASA of good 38
37 years in the fire service um when we
were initially working on on this we
looked at uh uh Homeland Security and
Homeland Security's definition of first
responder and we kind of tossed that
around but we didn't want to necessarily
add a new definition in But to answer
U representative Simon or Matt whatever
um to answer your initial question of
where we got our you know where where
you could find the definition uh
according the federal uh um federal law
6 USC 101 colon 6 can can slow that down
and give it to me again the law is
enacted by Congress from 2002 to
president it's it's
defined yeah the the actual number the
federal number six
USC
101 uh colon 6 okay great and that
basically is the defines emergency
response provider and that says that it
means federal state and local
governmental and non-governmental
emergency public safety fire law
enforcement emergency response emergency
medical including hospital emergency
facilities and related Personnel
agencies and authorities okay so that's
the federal uh when Homeland Security
was formed they came up with a
definition that also uh applies it goes
into other agencies but basically
Homeland Security said this is the
definition that we're going to use to
define emergency response providers and
have we gone outside of that definition
here are there more people involved than
are in that definition this definition
is is a very Global definition and I
think we and here in New Hampshire we're
trying to kind of tighten that up a
little bit okay because confidentiality
is pretty much what drives everything
that we do yeah uh as far as a peer
support team and members of a peer
support team so we were just trying to
be perhaps too specific but we want to
make sure that we covered everyone that
may be uh to your point sir uh we want
to to cover everyone that may be
impacted by a traumatic event right uh
yeah just for clarification purposes the
only reason why I asked was because
originally representative PR had
mentioned potentially wanting to attach
the definition to that um but that is
not exactly what we have in this bill
and so uh just from the preference so
that we can discuss it from the
preference of you guys um was the hope
to connect it actually in RSA to that
federal statute or do you want to stick
with the definition that you've come up
with I I think we stick with the
definition that we've come up with um I
was I'm just here trying to to answer
your specific question on where where we
sort of some more additional background
information yep perfect I appreciate it
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee
no okay um are we good with the
definition
component okay um so my next question
further down on page one uh starting in
line 22 that paragraph CR critical
incident stress management and crisis
intervention services means consultation
peer support we're striking counseling
uh debriefing diffusing intervention
services management prevention and
referral provided by a critical incident
Str stress management team and or team
member
um the question that I have is is it
necessary from your perspective to put
in team if a single team member is all
that's
necessary so I I guess we provide like
two different kinds of service right you
have the pier oneon-one and we do
debriefings and diffusing which is a
team effort at least two to three people
go we sit in a room with 15 20 people
whoever were involved in the incident
and de brief them and then so it may be
a team thing but if you want to just
leave it as a team member that one team
member making
U the
referral no I actually know it's helpful
the reason why I asked the question is
to bring out I think what you did so the
debriefing and defusing those are two
things that would more likely be a team
there is a team that provides a service
and then there can be just one team
member that provid the service yeah let
me just I I'll think about that a little
bit as far as potential wording or
thoughts on it but it's probably not
life or death but I just wanted to know
why the differentiation between the two
um anything from the
committee uh we talked about the third
one that I had which was on line one um
we talked about the paragraph anything
else um on page two the addition of the
hospital emergency department personnel
before we move on from that one I think
we talked about that for a bit
so that's just them adding the
Department we we talked about exposure
and potentially trying to find some your
am well the amendment that I have here
yes it's actually represented PR's
Amendment but 033 3H this is where you
had brought up your concerned about
other people who were outside of the
emergency department but we can have
that discussion and try to figure out
but just wanted to make sure there were
no more questions on those on that
particular phrase there before we move
on past
it I think we okay um next line 26 the
team shall be registered with the
icisf which we know who that is or a
similar organization which I know
frequently pops up in statute it's not
unheard of to put that language in it's
a little bit boilerplate um just curious
who that or who those other
organizations may be that might come
into play um and then it says to
maintain training standards to date as
required I'm assuming as required by
icisf yes yes and then
um what H who who holds you accountable
if you do not hold those standards as
required does icisf handle it or do we
handle it who's holding you accountable
for not meeting those standards because
we're giving you the right in in statute
right to do this um so if the only
people overseeing you are icisf I just
have a question about that yeah it would
be the icisf and the and the director of
safety also helps oversee and I identify
any of those other uh training entities
or organizations that uh teams are
allowed to be trained by okay so
director of safety so if we threw
in potentially something about the
director of safety that would be
something that you're doing presently
correct okay um I just want to make sure
that we potentially have that in there
so that there is some someone having to
do with the state of New Hampshire that
has a say and and what's going
on
good okay
um any anything from anybody else on
that particular section good all right
uh line 28 all critical incident stress
management team members sworn civilian
or retired we get the retired in there
um shall be designated by police chief
sheriff director of the division of
state police fire chief commissioner of
the Department of Corrections
superintendent of County Corrections
chief of Emergency Medical Services
director of the division of emergency
services and Communications or the head
of a union of Emergency Response Public
Safety workers as defined by RSA 281 A2
obviously some of those are already in
statute you're adding some um is this
Universal so if somebody if the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections
um designates a critical incident stress
management team member can that team
member work across all disciplines or is
it specific to the Department of
Correction CS so they could provide
support services to all First Responders
okay all First
Responders and from your experience
you're comfortable with all of those
people making that call yes sir
okay
um okay so this I think we added my next
question which is anything from the
committee on page two before we go to
page three
okay um I think we answered my next
question we added nor any person
receiving any critical in incident
stress management and Crisis
Intervention that was specifically for
retired people but is the scope intended
to be larger than that do you have
somebody else in mind other than retired
individuals not at this time sir okay I
do it may be something that we should
discuss especially if you already have
that question and we have the
opportunity to put it in there now it
may be very important to make sure it's
very clear that that is the population
we're intending to support there are the
retirees I agree with you on that yeah I
just don't I don't want to go out
outside of the scope of what you're
looking for and accidentally add in
other people that we're not intending to
so this is specifically for retired
individuals to making sure that all of
all First Responders receiving services
are protected to include retirees yes
sir okay very
good anything else from the
committee yeah I I would almost leave it
any person receiving I hear any yeah
sorry you gotta talk I would leave it
any person receiving critical incident
stress
interventions are are
covered yeah I only because no I
understand what you're saying and I'm
not trying to like y create a problem in
there
um I don't know I like to hear actually
Mr user Hut's thoughts on it potentially
he might be helpful on this
um I'm not sure I'm not sure if that
jumps out at me as Continuum of
Care after they're retired because
they're no longer appear at that point
we haven't defined
that so we can add
retirees or any person receiving
critical in stress
intervention we we'll work on it we'll
throw it back past you to make sure that
whatever if we change it you know it's
it's you're comfortable with it you
don't have any concerns that we're not
thinking of um uh but I just want to
make sure it's clear so that you know
and then um and then later on line five
you add disclosed which makes sense so
you're getting both the person providing
the service and receiving the service
involved there which makes sense to me
anyway um so that will lead us down to
line 13 and following um where we're
changing the definition slightly of um
what is deemed
confidential um or we committee
comfortable moving on to that
point
okay um just walk us through why you
changed what you changed and what you're
hoping to it'll accomplish yeah
absolutely we're genuinely hoping that
the committee doesn't see it as a change
but more of a clarification okay um and
making sure that we're very clearly
defining for everybody uh when and how
we need to get our folks additional
Support Services when they need it um
looking at the statute we were concerned
and and other departments coming on
board with offering peer support
services was were also looking for some
clarification so that's why we really
leaned into um providing that Clarity to
make sure that it's truly understood
when somebody is a danger to thems or
somebody else and they not only
articulate a means but an intent that
we're able to get them help um when when
a crime has been committed or is about
to be committed we absolutely need to to
get an individual help to stop that from
happening or to prevent that from
happening um and then obviously when
there's ever a threat of violence or
danger or crime against the vulnerable a
vulnerable population our adults or
excuse me our juveniles or our elderly
that that's all information that we are
all as humans in the state of New
Hampshire mandated reporters and
required to get more assistance to for
those individuals to and report that
information to the appropriate entities
um so when we created the statute in
2013 we really wanted to make sure that
those things were very clear um but
since we have evolved and we are growing
we saw the need to make it a little bit
more clearer yeah so you're flushing it
out a little bit more adding adding a
little bit more description okay any
questions okay gentlemen thank you very
much unless there's something else you
want to add I think that brings us to
the end and I want to give other people
a chance for get a few more minutes on
this one if they want to share great
greatly appreciate your time yeah
absolutely thank you for coming in it's
very helpful in fact we wouldn't have
been able to do it without you so yeah
did anybody else want to share anything
on this there's quite a few of you guys
out
there
no all right I will um close this uh
hearing or hearing or whatever
discussion on
1079 let's take just a couple minute
break and we'll come back to do
all right let back at it guys a lot of
work today gentlemen if you guys would
just like to join us at the table
there's nobody else so we might as well
be friendly it'll make it
easier uh I'm going to start with
representative
Brown he has given us an amendment and
uh why don't you walk us through that
okay so apologies it's not in it's not
in format yet uh been working with uh
oplc and with the the uh Deputy adant
General to come up with an amendment
that worked for um both of them and
for the sponsors of the bill so I've
given you the original
Bill and I've handwritten in on there
the changes
that are in the amendment try to make it
easier for you to
track the amendment with the red is
actually um at OS now and I told them
when I we were done today I would go
down and give them the last comment so
they can draft it up properly uh do you
have did you do you guys have one to
look at what are he's talking about yeah
okay
cool
um so uh I was not here for the original
hearing because I zoned it and I was in
exec session at fishing game as the
clerk fortunately for me Daniel papovich
Miller was here as a
co-sponsor he said he goes to hearings
for billly co-sponsors so got to give
him credit for for being here to save
that so and I think originally uh uh the
chair said she might have thought there
was some feeling that the bill might not
be necessary and we can talk through
that with the gentleman here but I think
now that we've kind of gotten this far
that we're at a good place with thinking
that it's something that we should move
forward with so that kind of being where
it's at that um you have the the the the
version with the red lettering on is the
amendment and if you need to ask what
change I have it highlighted in the
original
Bill okay so you added the the one line
on um this sheet that you gave me in
red uh under B license shall include
licenses certifications or registrations
required to practice a regulated
occupation or commerate training an
experience in a military occupational
specialty is determined by the LC that's
added language I yes and I added that
and I don't know attorney a house has
had the has had the time to really take
that in and he probably has a better
idea of how to say that I'm
sure since I did that at one o'clock
this morning yes well I have one from
you I've got one from him I've got stuff
all over the place for this one so we'll
uh we'll wait our way through and the
committee members can stop and ask
questions just yell at me if you got
questions and and actually I would I
would add to that from the original Bill
to the
amendment with oplc a number of the
tasks that we gave to the veterans
agency was suggested that OPC should do
that which is why when you get to page
two of the original Bill most of it's
deleted and it's
now Incorporated in the amendment or
it's already in what oplc would do
anyway
okay yeah and I I believe that
representative leus asked that question
during the original hearing about
whether or not oplc was doing some of
this or should be doing some of this or
I think he asked that question so that's
probably enough for me to start great
thank
you would you like to make some comments
on it gentlemen we we're getting it for
the first time so I haven't had time to
judgest it yet you
want you want me to good morning Doug
PLC for for the record
subit okay too formal I get it take my
tie off uh do you me to address the the
comment on line b or just kind of an
overall statement um overall statement
on it so that we can get an an idea of
where you are and then once we've done
that if you want to add in what you've
done and what you'd like to see in there
that would be great um so I think I
think overall what what we're going to
see the progress here is not necessarily
going to be a speed up of the processing
of the application on the opl side but
what we're going to see is a stream Ling
of kind of what comes before that so
we're going to clarify what is required
for lure in the state and how that you
know the military service and the
training and experience translate to the
licensing here and then what we're also
going to see with the VAP is uh licenses
coming to the oplc that are complete and
ready to go and they're ready to be
processed and when we have a complete
application I mean sometimes our
turnaround can be same day um and it's
going to be less than two weeks
regardless so we can we can turn a a a
complete a completed application around
very quickly so I think that's where
we're going to see the benefit from from
this statute is sort of everything that
predicates that application coming into
the oplc and when it comes in correctly
we get it right out the door and so I
see that that same changed language is
in this amendment on page two 30 days
after having received we don't have that
same language that we did before right
well that yeah I think my concern in in
1385 is originally proposed was it has
this language about 15 days 10 days and
then we would need to submit something
in writing and get approval if we have
to go and it it deviated so far from
541a and shortened shortened the leas a
little too much and I I it could have
been problematic I think the language in
the new bill kind of allows us more
reasonable time frames to turn this over
and I I think we're okay with just for
the subcommittees benefit
problematic from the standpoint if you
miss that deadline to reject the we
would have had no if it was an
incomplete or inaccurate application and
we didn't get approval timely from
another agency we would have been forced
to deny in my opinion and that makes
everybody start the process over so here
we just extend that timeline a little
bit longer and we're able to turn things
around without being put in that
situation where it's yes or no on the
spot mhm thank you yeah thanks keep
going anything
else uh are we going to talk more
specifically about the language as
specifically as you would like to talk
about like I haven't I haven't had a
chance yet so I can't be as specific as
I usually like to be sure I'm just
reading
it okay uh the colonel is recommending
uh that I I addressed something right
out front uh representative Brown came
to was this morning and added a on the
last page of the document a section D it
says the rule shall be complete by XXXX
2025 yes you see that
I I understand the impotence behind that
right to make sure these happen it is a
little concerning because it's not
necessarily in our control and we have a
lot of stakeholders we're going to have
to work with in order to make this
happen um if we want that sort of that
so from the LLC perspective we're going
to start work on this and this is
something we want to have happen and
we're we're going to make it happen um
as much as we can um that hard timeline
is always scary from an attorney's point
of view right we miss that deadline
there's objections there's stakeholder
feedback we weren't expecting now we're
out of compliance with the law I'm
wondering if we
could my suggestion was potentially make
it file an IP or an initial proposal
that way we would still have that time
to work I we hadn't discussed that yet
no and so backing up a little bit in um
you have the original you have the law
there
332 so when that was passed and and I'm
I'm uh telling you what director
Courtney said to me so you're getting it
secondhand so take that as you may
um so the intent of this was to to to
basically have a crosswalk if you're
this in the military you should be able
to get this in New Hampshire whatever
that is doesn't matter could be
electrician could be a pharmacy tech we
went with medical initially but and
director Courtney said to me well we put
this in the law a little while ago that
all boards would have to do this in
rulem which is what it says in
there but she told me and you can you
can you know fix this up as as necessary
that most of them have either not
started at all or they're not done one
of one or the
both so yeah I'll just finish up so I I
I I have complete faith and the director
and and attorney have told me that they
will get to this immediately for all
boards under
oplc however those that aren't EMS so
again if you're a medic a Corman can you
be an EMT or an EMR crossover
apparently they haven't done those rules
yet um there's there are some already in
place where there's automatic crossover
so so putting D in was for me to try to
get those boards that haven't started
this off dead center basically so there
must there can be a better way to do
this it's fine so you're going outside
of oplc there you're doing all boards
regardless right does that include the
bar it would include include the bar
right now uh the the other issue with
that
is um where it's placed right now
is oh no this is under 541a
yeah it this looks like it's amending
31016 which is specifically limited to
the oplc
boards is that is that I think well
excuse me my intent was on the bottom of
that second page under number four for
all of you on the bottom oh men 332 G
okay right and that'll be more clear I'm
more comfortable with that now I thought
that was actually put
in because this is the first I've seen
this version to okay um I see what
you're saying so cutc out there and
we're we're switching it over to to
anyone to any so yeah so OPC will will
take all the boards that they have under
their purview but that leaves a few that
EMS and and uh the certifications under
Wastewater and water and those kind of
things that leaves them outside of
oplc this doesn't change what they
should have been doing but you're just
I'm trying to find a way to say do it
however that is I I don't care so you
feel more comfortable because oplc is
not on the hook the board Is Well
everybody's on the hook uh so I don't I
mean it's not completely alleviated it
it's
not I I I would say there's still
implications yeah I would still those
other boards that are not covered by
oplc there are still implications if
they don't get the rules done and Rule
making you in my experience my very
limited experience and I'm not an
attorney is an arduous process it's
miserable it's a miserable process right
necessary and and and very important to
protect the rights of both the citizens
of New Hampshire and the state but it's
it you know trying to get something done
in a year of this magnitude may be very
very hard what would your what would
your recommend Commendation be for a
timeline then I I think the shall have
submitted an initial proposal
language
gets it it lights that fire and it makes
people do the work but it says you know
if we get fogged down and there's
further conversation that needs to
happen in the 541a and jail car process
we're not going to put anybody out of so
for the benefit of the subcommittee once
the initial proposal is filed I think
then you would have who
where does the train go from there like
is it outside like once it started can
it stop or is it is it on the train to
completion until it's done it can stop
it can stop and that's the danger and
and I also want to second that I think
one of the driving forces behind this is
is it is very true that this has existed
in statute for a decade and there has
not been a lot of progress on it
so two-tier dat so that's an interesting
I mean that's an interesting point the
other alternative is two date initial
proposal by 2025 completed by and then
extend that deadline out a little bit
extend the deadline out for a completion
six months even six months because more
than more than a miserable process I
think it's the timeliness of of Ru
making that is is the concern uh one
second you talking about converting
Moss's to civilian Specialties is that
what we're talking about here is that
why it's going to take so long I I just
no I I don't think that's the the the
problem at all I think the problem is I
I don't think that's going to be the
issue I mean we're going to be able to
we'll be able to advise the boards and
oplc what military experience and
training equates to will be able to come
you know we'll be able to work with the
board and kind of make those
determinations I just think that and and
again it was tongue and- cheek comments
about ruem it's difficult right it
really is that's my experience it's not
you know so uh I think that the it's
just getting through the the
requirements you know the legal ease you
know getting through the requirements of
getting the rules drafted sometimes it
takes a long time even the simplest
rules that we proposed for the
Department you know two years ago took
18 months to finish and they weren't
they weren't difficult rules I mean
simple and and I'm also referring to
consensus building reaching out to
stakeholders getting in public input uh
for those kind of things both from
military expertise and also the like IES
in the state so just so we can work with
people just giving us enough time and I
might be right I'm also advocating to be
a bit over cautious here so so we don't
find ourselves in a situation where
we're in violation of the law and I'd
like to see that timeline extended just
so that doesn't happen that's where I'm
coming
from that representative boy that is
exactly the original tent of what we
were looking to do and and uh University
of Washington has got a great crosswalk
and it's it's huge for because there's
so many Moss's it's mostly a military
crossw walk about that says these are
these MOS equal this um the Veterans
Affair office has something called uh uh
Corman to IMT that so the VA created
created a
position intermediate medical
technician IMT techn technician I think
where if you were a Corman you you can
basically automatically be that it's not
quite that simple but so that is kind of
what we were looking for and that I It
guess is sort of my expectation of the
rules I I I can't imagine the difficulty
of writing that in rule language but
that's that well that's that's a good uh
point you talk of Corman so you're
talking Navy I happen to be greenb medic
I spent 37 weeks training and I'm
equivalent to to a PA but how is that
going to be
established you know rather than just
eweek basic medic course right EXA
exactly sir and and and you know I'm
familiar I'm not I wasn't a green brave
but I was 28 years in the Army and you
know I'd rather have doc patch me up
than go to the hospital frankly I mean
you and you know you live that right so
but again I'm not talking about figuring
out that crosswalk to find out if that
training equals license board licensing
requirements I think we can do that real
relatively quickly it's the process by
which we codify that in administrative
rules that carry the way to law over
time I think that's where it starts to
take more time we can figure those
things out I mean there there are
systems representative Brown referred to
that exist we don't even have to make
them up they exist we can pull the
crosswalk off the internet or off the
American Council for uh American Council
for
Education by which they advise colleges
and universities to Grant credit based
on military service and Military TR
training so we we have the groundwork to
get that done it's really just it's just
the process of making sure we get the
rules right to protect both the state of
New Hampshire and you know the licensing
boards and the citizens in New Hampshire
that's where it's going to take loes
talk
good
okay
nice if represent Simon if I could just
make a couple of comments just overall
yes like this is great legislation right
so if we didn't do it we'd be okay and
if we do do it we're going to be great
right so I would tell you that the
department has a tremendous and robust
relationship with oplc with regard to
licensing and military transfer of
transfer of military training to lure
experience to lure it's not as codified
as it maybe it should be I mean the
department as it exists today and the
requirements for us to do this in the
department only came about in about 2020
in statute so we We're Young at it we do
have a we do have a uh a person on staff
her name is Erica Webb who does this so
we we are we are you Cally in bed with
oplc to make sure that we can do
whatever we can
do uh to help veterans or currently
serving members of the military get
licensing and oplc has done a tremendous
amount of work you know one of the
things that surprised me very recently
was when covid started if you were an
army medic you're automatically or you a
medic in the military you're
automatically can get an LNA license
automatically it's there right I think
there's a three-year requirement but
what a tremendous thing and so we want
to help advertise that kind of stuff
because most people don't know that that
exists so that's the first thing I would
like to say second thing is we're
working with director Courtney and and
the folks at oplc they've got a request
for proposal out to rewrite all of their
administrative rules and we are going to
have input from the veteran perspective
to make sure that we are considering mil
milary experience and training so that
we can as as it pertains to licensing so
that's the second thing I would
say uh the third thing is as I mentioned
we're going to use existing systems to
kind of sus out how MOS transfers or
military occupational specialty or Air
Force specialty code or you know or
whatever we call it in the rates in the
Navy uh how that translates to licensing
you know and primarily we want to use
the American Council on education
because they have a very robust system
that looks at uh you know if you were a
medic and you were promoted to Sergeant
as a medic and at that level you were
expected to do these things in your the
occupational specialty awarded it equals
this many credits towards a uh a med a
health degree so we could take that and
they automatically line up with
licensing requirements we can take that
and make that work
uh uh two things two last comments is we
don't approve licensing so it's like in
this process and one of the things we're
really happy about in the rewrite of in
the the proposed amendment that uh
representative Carol's brought by is
that there's no confusion right so the
veteran himself has got to justify he's
got a the burden of proof on experience
rests on the
veteran the burden to issue a license
rests at oplc and our job is to
facilitate that in the department right
so we want to make sure that the veteran
has a resource they can go to to
translate the requirements of the
licensing to what they know and we can
get them in the right place and the last
thing I want to say is we don't think
this is going to create a tremendous
increase in demand to the system right
so of the boards that oplc manages just
a cursory look without a whole bunch of
work going on we only think there are
about somewhere between 12 and 18 boards
that may even be relevant in this
process and we will look at the
occupational Specialties across the
Department of Defense
we don't think that's a very high
density piece most most people in the
military are you know combat arms and
the professionals the logisticians and
the Medics they're a smaller cohort of
of the military so the people that might
even qualify based on Military
experience is going to be small just
based on what's going on than the
recency of your license you're a you
know like you're a dock you were you
were you were a team doc but those you
know those skills have degraded you
wouldn't necessarily be comfortable
doing some of those things today or as
comfortable as you were when you were on
an 18 team 50 years ago yeah and there's
been some advances in medical technology
right so just you know just so so so so
even then the the the proximity of or
the timeliness of your your separation
from the military is going to shrink
that population so we don't think this
is going to create a tremendous Demand
on the system but what it is going to do
is create a tremendous this opportunity
for us to make sure people have an ease
of getting licenses and everybody
benefits from that employers benefit
from it electricians plumbers uh Medics
everybody benefits from that so it's a
it's a good thing that we can do but I
mean the floodgates aren't going to open
we're not going to see a thousand people
or request licenses we we might see 40 a
year just based on just based on
population so those are the things that
I that I would kind of
mention
represent schi so I I think your remarks
just now are very very important for us
because otherwise we we it's a black box
we don't have any idea what what's in
there how it would work what impact it
would have so knowing that it's 40 and
not a thousand or and that that's very
important for us to know what we're what
we're loading on our back or not
so that's very helpful to me and I I'm
sure to everybody else as
well okay I've had a chance to read it
it's
helpful no it's perfect and I heard what
you said as well so it's
okay uh so uh representative Brown nice
job catching the executive director
thing in paragraph two on the second
page oh yeah okay I was going to say
that that jumps that like literally
jumps off the page at you now it's like
wait a second um question um Mr
osterhout
um this where was
it we have a reference to this for
temporary license should we change that
to conditional
license so uh paragraph B page two the
applicant must submit a notorized
affidavit affirming under penalty of law
that the applicant is a person described
and identified in the application that
all statements made on the the
application are true and correct and
complete that the applicant has read and
understands the requirements for the
license certifies that they meet their
requirements and the applicant is good
standing in all jurisdictions in which
the applicant holds or is held a license
or is not subject to discipline and
jurisdictions that's not even the one I
wanted C the next one is the one I
wanted the applicant May request a one
time 180 day extension of the temporary
license if necessary to complete the New
Hampshire licensing requirements the
applicant must make the request within
15 days prior to the expiration of the
temporary
license do we do temporary licenses
anywhere did we change that to
conditioner license
conditional
license so there might be some confusion
on that is
is so temporary license was a big thing
during covid right just to get Workforce
right in the door um conditional
licenses have a similar purpose in
that we can get somebody working without
having to wait the 90 days for their
criminal background check pending other
Protections in place so which seems like
that's what you're doing here it is what
we're doing here and that might just be
actually that's where it is it starts in
a the applicant shall obtain a temporary
license for a period not less than 180
days while completing the requirements
for licensure in the New Hampshire so
long as the cost for denial of the
license exists uh no cost for denial of
license exists under this title or under
any other law I under 31016 that whole
section is about ter temporary lure okay
I think from a practical point of view
depending on how that plays out in rule
it can sort of refer to one or the other
so there might be instances where
conditional or temporary might be
somewhat interchangeable I don't know if
that's 100% accurate um if you can find
out what the better word is yeah so that
if we do this we put the better word
into I can take a look at that and then
see which
word we want to put in there applicant
May request it one
time yes representative Brown uh thank
you so yes the the change that that
entire piece is in there but the change
was the addition of two and three and
bold below that and it was included
because she had to
change um Roman numeral one 2 and three
to Roman numeral one ABC d right so
that's why that whole thing I don't need
to tell you that I guess I'm sorry no um
but our our our intent with this was not
to ask for temporary or a quick license
it was just to ask for a fair
process that doesn't make a a
veteran take courses and take an exam
that they shouldn't have to do that's
basically the idea so but I and I would
ask a the gentleman at the table I the
reason on the on the first page that I
added commensurate training experience
in a military occupational
specialty is because I didn't see it
specific I wasn't sure if it was
specific in the new two and three on
this page
too
so I just want to be clear that
somewhere there the the veterans we're
talking about are not included in Roman
numeral one spouse temporary license
temporary licenses so I want to make
sure that it's clear in the words that
where they are included and I thought I
had added it to either two or three but
apparently I didn't I think I might have
thrown that in one of myund can probably
help you there y so I
sometimes I'm better than myself and I
looked at my notes from the other thing
I do think looking at C now that should
stay temporary license but is referring
specifically to the temporary licenses
and that was not a change that was part
of the amendment that was there's a
little bit of redlining in what is
already existing Statute in here just to
clean up the language of 31016 okay if
it doesn't happen we can live with the
language as is but I just that was kind
of tighten up the langu language thing
just a recommendation while we had it
open so I do think that piece should
stay temporary license okay there um as
far as the definition I'm I am there is
a concern about putting or commiserate
training and experience in a military
occupational specialty as determined by
the oplc in the very definition of
license because to me I think the
argument could be made that if I have
that training there's no reason to go
through the licensing process so I like
the that language I don't think um just
not there I just not there yeah uh where
we want to put that I'm not I originally
had bracketed um the new section three I
think it could also fit right below that
I'm on page two in that amendment to 332
g74 a I'm wondering if it could fit
there but if you want it in
31016 um I could play around with it but
my my gut reaction was Roman numeral 3
the new proposed Roman numeral 3 okay
but I I'd want to look at that more
closely because that this morning the
first time I saw Roman numeral 3 meaning
what you gave me were correct yes okay
so the it reads the executive deor shall
in consultation with the boards councils
and commissions yeah so well I that fits
right for what constitutes military
education training or service acceptable
for this specific regulated occupation
and it seems like this commiserate
training and experience fits right in
with that section
three yes I agree but that falls under
the does because it comes under military
service members and spouse will
temporary licensure does that negate
that am I reading it wrong or am I
thinking way too
hard say that again for me sorry so the
new Roman numeral 3 is still under the
uh the title military at the top of the
page military service members and
spousal temporary
lure so a a person who has gotten out of
the military is not a military service
member nor a spouses so that might be a
good time to
change the title of the section of
3106 to make it a little broader and
just have
it office of professional Li Insurance
certification military service M members
and spouses take out temporary licenses
from the title then we have it one kind
of addresses the title and two and three
sort of address the long-term rule
making that we're talking about here or
the long-term lure that we're talking
about here and and and and we just
clarify the title a little more and we
expand it to two and three by removing
those temporary licensure rewards from
the from the top there and and I know
that you know what I'm asking for
but it's still doesn't say that this is
for a what's the right word a separated
after someone is initially out of the
military honorable a veteran just a
veteran it doesn't say that honorable
discharge I mean it says it in the well
it does say it in at the beginning of
the entire change to the law it's a the
veterans veterans license program so
maybe it's covered there but that does
that make sense yeah I I think I think
my reading of it is is sort of implicit
in that we're talking military education
training experience on its own I I read
it implicit in that statement even if it
isn't explicitly there I I don't know
what
other sorry no I cut you off so I would
say it's not important that they're
separated or serving what's important is
they have the training right so the
status of the veteran here is less
important then the they're able to uh
they have the burden of proof that they
have the training on them right so if
they're still serving in the guard or
the reserves and they have the training
or if they're separated and they have
the training and it's current in
accordance with the rules then I I I
think that's more important that they
can substantiate that they have the
training and experience than it is what
their status is currently serving a
veteran service member that's a that's a
good
point there's no reason why somebody who
has the experienc and is still enlisted
shouldn't be able to apply for a license
and receive one is there not so you can
plan ahead of time you know you're
heading towards retirement and you want
to make the change you can get the work
done before you're actually in the
situation and then just seamlessly walk
over does this allow for that we can do
it in rule I think okay that's what this
would allow for
okay again I'm not a lawyer but it
doesn't preclude it right no I wanted to
make sure that yeah I wanted to make
sure that it was that I think that's a
fantastic fantastic way of going about
it so I just wanted to make sure that
that was an Avenue that we could that we
could and mostly mostly in New Hampshire
right so in terms of population again
back to representative smid's comments
earlier we we don't have a we only have
about 1,200 actively serving non-reserve
members of the military in New Hampshire
most of them recruiters they work at New
Boston tracking station you know there's
not a lot of actively serving regular
guys everybody else to the tune of about
5,000 are in the reserve components so
they're currently serving they're
currently performing you know that one
weekend a month two weeks a year if
they're not deployed their military
Mission flight Medics you know the guys
who pluck the you know hikers off out of
the White Mountains and the helicopters
that we send up there those guys are
they're absolutely licensed in the
National register of emt's licensed they
are so and you know electricians you
know some construction Engineers
plumbers they could do that so again not
to belabor it you know the horse kind of
turned into glue here but that's our job
right
so but but it's more important that they
can demonstrate the training and
experience than it is what their status
is in the military in this particular
case I believe
that okay Mr chair yes what so would it
would it be simple just to add the word
veteran in the
title to to shut me
up so in in the term of art yeah veteran
or active duty though I mean or maybe
not maybe that's I mean we could it says
well it says military service member
right veteran military service member
and spouse the term of art we use in the
department is service member veterans
and their families there you go yeah
let's let's let's do that that sounds
anybody else concerns you got that
concern looked on your there
peterc Peter mik that's all right if if
we've got people out there who could
be gainfully and
beneficially doing something benefit
themselves and also people in the state
of New
Hampshire and the only reason they're
not doing it is because they don't have
that little check mark or whatever then
we're we're wasting an opportunity and
we're also not only not benefiting it's
not it's not only that we're not taking
the money off the
table we
we're we're polluting the situation
because those are people who
are could be doing something and it's
potentially messing with their minds
that they can't do what they what they
want to do and what they would benefit
every everybody wins if we do it so
let's get on it let me follow up on that
that's a great Point uh r Schmidt and
and I think these guys have both heard
the story so let me give you the
two-minute story where this came from
our
son as a senior in high school said I
want to be in the Navy he did his early
uh uh early entrance for the first year
he went off to uh Great Lakes graduated
from his basic
training September 13 2001 so we knew
where he was going to be going right
right off right he did three tours in
Iraq uh he was in the Square the day of
the the bag in Baghdad the day the
statue came now so he was with the
three4 with the
Marines um then throughout throughout
his 14 years he was a pharmacy tech for
three years he worked in the hospital in
Primary Care in Naples Italy for three
years uh so he had a number of
experiences and I showed you his uh I
think I gave you his
uh tell me what it is list it's a it's
the military list of your
experience and so 10 years ago he got
out and and we said to him well you
should be able to be an LNA or or
something like that and he said I can't
he said unless I go to classes and take
a test and and you know between all of
us here it's not for everyone to know
but he came home as representative
Schmidt said he sat in a funk for six
months because he really wanted to stay
in but that's another that's another
story but so that what your point I'm
agreeing wholeheartedly with your point
that some of these people that get out
of the service that was their life and
that's what they want to keep doing and
I think that's the point of this to to
bring in those people that have that
Public Service uh already that that
dedication to public service so thank
you I appreciate because the alternative
to a win-win situation is a lose lose
situation and that that makes no sense
you know uh so you know I've been out
for uh since 195 58 um so it
was I don't remember everything from
those days but I do remember MOS and and
my my MOS was oh what was it Riflemen
Marines are all
Riflemen uh so but the point is that
when somebody use the word Corman I'm
going Bing I remember doc Hornback who
was the Corman attached to my unit now I
I have no idea what he actually what his
train was but but when we had anything
medical we got doc horn back in and so
forth uh and so so that's a term of art
to me an MOS is a term of art so those
things all mean something and to the
degree that that this this MOS means the
same as LNA or whatever and we're not
letting that person do that that's a
lose lose situation and I'm sure your
son was going like oh that's not good
I'm sitting around but the the the good
end of the story is he ended up working
at the VA Hospital on White River and
he's in Tilton now and he was used in
the emergency room during covid so it
it's all ended up very nicely Happ happy
to
say um but the but the magic word here
was commensurate training and experience
right in red and that thing so to the
degree that they are commen
then let's get at
it can I make one more comment because I
think we are talking about two different
classes of lensy and applicants here and
I'm looking at the the the red line on
the first page the commerate training
and experience um I'm not sure Roman
numeral 3 on its own is sufficient which
is why I'm struggling because you're
going to have individuals under the oplc
and individuals not under the oplc and
we want to make sure that language
applies to everyone not just it seems to
be the intent so it might be might be
worth putting that language in two
places not just sure that definition I
just want to yeah flag that
okay so you're saying three doesn't
cover oplc three would cover oplc it
wouldn't cover people outside of the
oplc okay because three that Roman
numeral three is a modification of three
yeah I'm sorry I was thinking four for
some reason four in my head so so maybe
that's why I was struggling because it
maybe it should be in both yeah would
you okay yep yeah because four is when
we break out to 332g right right three
um 74 so I I just want if we want it
applicable to everybody let's put it in
two places sure
um
so the third page we we never
really came to a conclusion on what we
wanted to do with that as far as the
date understand the desire for the date
um I'd like to find something that's
somewhat acceptable to anybody how do
you feel about an initial proposal by 25
and then
finalized uh Rules
by July 1st 2026 I I mean I'll defer to
the expertise of all of you in the room
I mean I've been involved with the dees
with rules and it's a solid
year if you're lucky I guess I mean
there's an official timeline that uh
that put out
but so I I I I'm okay with okay yeah I
mean I guess anything to just move this
off dead center is the right yeah
exactly I was going to say we've never
done it so a year and a half from now is
better than or two years from now is
better than never
and and with the that's not to say that
we wouldn't get those rules sooner just
you know like if you light the fire
sometimes people're like oh we've got a
deadline we better get moving they might
get them done faster than the deadline
but we just don't want to
I agree IP 25 final rules 26 it's great
okay well in addition to to have some
certainty as opposed to it's
com human mind does not like uncertainty
and to the degree that you know well
I've got a week or a month or a year or
whatever at at least it's something but
we got to make it that means something
so it's not just your promise will be
done in in in three weeks and it it
doesn't happen so and and I would I
would also argue that you know based on
the relationship we have with oplc and
the department has with with what
they're doing we're going to be doing
this before the rules get published
anyway right so if we can if we can
facilitate the license absent a
requirement in a statute we're going to
do it and so we'll be
okay yeah and I I find myself doing this
more and more and I don't know if I
should be but I'm kind of I'm making
sure other agencies have an opportunity
to know this is coming and give them an
opportunity to get eyes on to I think
from the oplc perspective I agree this
is something we want to do and we're
going to get started right
away and actually Mr chair that's a
question I have for you so because this
this addition to pushing the non-opc
boards to do this work has just been put
in here no one knows on those sides that
that this language even exists so
is that
okay I
mean oh as far as public
hearing they wouldn't have had had a
chance to I guess I guess that is what
I'm asking
you the original one yeah at least an
opportunity to comment is I think yeah
the the original one only dealt with
oplc correct right the original bill so
yeah that would be that we can't do that
we'll get slapped for that one I'm
pretty sure
so from a timeline perspective what do
you want me to do or what do you want to
do it's not my bill anymore it's yours
but well technically it's ours because
you're still on this
ours yeah I I think we could do the
section one and the section two I
wouldn't right that wouldn't be non- ger
section four here that were section four
is the one I'm questioning section oh
those numbers are a little
backwards yeah that that should be three
and then four but I'm just talking
sections now I'm getting nerdy here
sorry um so just the section four would
be the the piece that would be
problematic I think so okay
yeah but the op without without a public
hearing on it that's what I was last
night when I was writing this I was
thinking I don't know how I don't know
how it works yeah I think Peter would
you agree with that it's outside the
scope we didn't give the other boards an
opportunity to know that it was coming
and participate in the public hearing
that's probably out that would probably
be non gerain
you have more experience than I
do
yeah or someone does it next year or or
we take a Senate bill and attach it to
that or we could I mean we have options
still ahead of us it's just so here's
here's the trick of where we're sitting
as a
committee um we have an exec session on
Wednesday that's supposed to be the last
exec session I'm sure the chair would
like for that to be the last exec
session we start throwing in more public
hearings we're going to have another
exec session for one bill everybody's
gonna have to come in for um there's the
there's always the possibility of asking
the Senate to amend and if we're
amendable to it ahead of time it'll be
an easy concurrence at the end um you
know you just always want to be careful
that it doesn't get screwed up doing it
that way too but that's an option you
know then we could just concur with it
but then that would have the opportunity
for a hearing on the other side and um I
think or no we would still have to bring
it back here wouldn't we well yes they
do something that we haven't done yeah
then we would have to concur but we
wouldn't have to have another public
hearing on it no no if there's been a
public hearing on one side one side it's
good yep okay that's what I thought so
that would be an option for you okay so
so my goal would be not to derail this
in any way for this year for this
session to move forward so certainly if
you have an idea in you know before
before next Wednesday they whether we
just pull that
out and try to amend that next
session which pushes it six months
farther out for those other boards yeah
I think we could probably get Senator
Pearl to agree to amend this in the
Senate I think so I don't think it would
be hard at all so when so if we took
four out here got it through the house
and it goes to Eda and Edna in the
Senate we'll just talk to Senator Pearl
when we figure out where it's going and
just say hey we're going to do this we
need your
help we have to make sure that's going
to happen I did get a senator on this
hang on senator birdell who I've never
spoken to so I don't she's easy she'll
do it yeah I got but Pearl's the head of
Edna
over CH I told you guys know more than I
do see we're here to help if we need
Senator B to sponsor the amendment that
that won't be hard that I could talk to
her that won't be hard I'm really not
seeing any of it as a problem I'm sure
probably like there are times I'm like I
don't feel that way about this I I agree
but the thing is we we have to make sure
that it does happen yeah because I don't
want to hear anything about next session
we're ready to do this right now well we
can have we can we can have a
conversation as a committee to at some
point about whether or not if that were
to pass in the Senate we're going to be
okay with it um just to get a pulse for
it um so you know and worst case
scenario so here's what I would say
worst worst case scenario is
honestly
we amend the language in the senate
senate ask for concurrence for some
crazy reason the house decides not to
concur with it but we go to a committee
of conference there's no way we're not
concurring without a committee of
conference we go to the committee of
conference the house says listen we just
can't do this and the Senate says well
we don't want to toss the whole bill so
we'll just strike our side and we'll
concur with you that that's worst case
scenario I don't see anything other than
that happening either you end up with
the language that we've got or the full
thing but I don't think you end up with
nothing I just don't see that happening
thank you thank you all um
so would would you like to make those
few changes and send that off to me or
before and OLS OS is waiting for he has
it he's waiting for whatever changes
that we want might want to make you want
to on the date or I can do it it might
be better written if you do it not the
only recommendation we're making is just
to I've got this bracket here just take
this one section out if we said that to
OS just cross that out everything else
can go as
is oh say it again sorry I think the
only recommendation we're making here
well I move the language out of line
three we or the the definition so we
want them actually maybe it's easier if
I just add the language and send it to
you today
okay okay you
want yes please is that okay yeah that
be great um any concerns from the
committee or anything anybody else want
to be tagged on
it and and Mr chair I have one more
question for you please if you all look
at the
original um on page
three
yes uh where it's deleted line 10 11 and
12 I'll wait for them to catch
up
the insurance component the original
Bill page three line 10 11 and 12 so in
this was a team effort there was 10 of
us working on this originally so
everybody had a bunch of different
pieces and and representative dun came
up with this piece about insurance
making sure
that somewhere someone talked to him and
said if this lure happens I think it was
because if it happens more quickly will
these people be covered by insurance and
I believe director Courtney
has looked at that and talked about it
but I want to make sure that we're on
the same page that we don't need to
State anything in that
fashion
well oh about the examination or test
component of
it so we've probably Fallen outside of
what that sentence says now but where
We've Ended up
right
you're saying because we're we're
providing the license without
potentially having to do the
examination if is do you know of an
instance where the insurance requires
the
test I mean if they've got a most most
of them care about license right they
they care that they're licensed I mean
we're they're looking I think anyway
most of the time they're looking to the
state to determine whether or not
they're just looking for a stamp of
approval that the state has looked at
them and said this person can practice
okay I think but I've never heard of
them okay and it might be maybe in the
earlier parts of this there was some
thought that it was an accelerated
process or that in some way there it
might have
been not as equal of a license maybe so
I I just want to make sure we're okay
getting rid of that I think so because
the force of the force of laws behind it
either way we've looked at it and said
this is an acceptable form of license
insure in the state of New Hampshire
whether it's temporary or you know the
full license this is how we've defined
it I've never heard of an insurance
company denying a licensed
individual insurance because they didn't
pass some other arbitrary exam of some
sort and I would say that I'm very
careful to say this right veterans
deserve a chance they deserve an
opportunity to compete but they don't
deserve a free pass right so they still
have to meet the requirements of the
license to get it so me I understand the
issue that some insurance companies may
be reluctant based on what they might
think the license is but at the end of
the day there's no expectation from the
department and there should be no
expectation from the veteran that they
don't that they get a license that
they're not otherwise qualified for so
they're not you know oplc is just not
going to give it out because they're a
veteran I don't know if I'm making any
sense no no I do but it brings up
another question you're right yeah it
brings up another question of is there
anything in this process from the oplc
side of things that they see commiserate
experience however they still would have
to pass this exam according to the board
in order to get the license would that
does that
exist I would say that's possible
depending on the license because the
board still has the right to set the
standard for the license correct so if
the board requires the examination they
may have all of the other credentials
but I would assume they would still have
to take the examination to get the
license which they should be able to do
if they actually have the experi
you know I I agree with you right but
but again I you I made it clear that our
department can't make those
determinations only only just kind of
get well and that's also something this
allows us to establish in rule so we can
we can do whatever we want yeah at that
point right as far as like to your to
your point setting the criteria for
licensure if they want the examination
because we need that then we can set the
examination and Rule and make that a
requirement but that's going to be the
recommendation of the board correct I
mean the board's going to look at it and
say I understand the military personnel
has all of this experience we're still
going to require them to take this
examination you know I can't speak for
the boards and there are 57 of them even
if only no I'm just saying if the board
came to you and said that that then the
military person oplc wouldn't be able to
override the board's opinion on that
would
they so the board says we want them to
take XYZ examination in order to be
licensed even though they have all this
commiserate experience get oplc look at
them and say nah
no I don't think that's gonna happen I
didn't think so yeah right in this
consultation with the boards and I know
there's there's always this question and
this tension about the final Authority
so I I see this as I mean it's the same
arguments I make often with advisory
boards and and 313 and those kind of
things it's that this is not happening
without consensus and working with the
boards now are they going to get what
they want 100% of the time I can't
guarantee that but we have opportunity
for public comment we have public
meetings we have the jail car and the
administrative 541a process like there
are controls in place so the board comes
and says in order to be able to do this
you need to pass that examination that
is not going to go
unheard Brown so our goal in a in a
perfect simple world would have been
reciprocity in essence that that's yep
if you're this you're this you don't
have to take classes or take a test
I mean that's that's that was the
original intent I agree I think that I
think my question is more I it was more
a question asked
to disprove the assertion than anything
else um I'm not sure that a board would
require an examination there like you
said there are 57 boards though there
might be some occupation out there in
which the overlap isn't perfect between
but they just said it's close enough
that if they can pass this examination
then we can give it to them you know
that was the only thing that was going
along in my mind otherwise they would
have to deny because it it wasn't
commiserate but they might be able to
look at it and say well it's close
enough if they can just do this one
extra thing then we can give them a
license and my question was just simply
in a situation like that opl's position
is what and it was what I expected it to
be because we've been doing this long
enough and I could give you kind of an
example that based on some legislation
that passed last session right so we we
passed the general court was generous
last year and passed some stuff at the
at the direction of oplc
that if you had 8,000 hours of
electrician experience in the military
you automatically qualified to be a
journeyman electrician you didn't have
to go through the apprentice license
right so that's just that's good that's
a great law but what we did find was not
necessarily push back from the boards
but push back from the electricians
union right so they're not so right so
they're not necessarily enamored with
this because now they lose control the
union lose control of the training
process right good bad right right wrong
or indifferent that's not an indictment
of anybody so there may be half of us
agree with you and half of us disagree I
I knew that was going to be is isn't
that the way that's why I said when you
run for office half to people
automatically hate you right that's how
it works so so you I'm not you it's
really not an indictment of that process
but I'm just saying that there may be
some instances where the boards would
say we want to be sure or there is some
pressure to the board from from external
sources that say we want to be sure so I
don't know if it's going to you know
what the law says one way or the other
but it's not necessarily just a done
deal because there'll be there'll be
some people who are really for this and
some people who think it's bad for the
system and you know the beautiful thing
for us is at that
point that's that's up to rules and and
the
boards until we get to Jael car and then
then then they can deal with it but I'm
not on that yet so away stay
away and and and the other thing the
point I like to make is I think
underpinning everything oplc does is
protection of the public right and we do
a disservice to the public if we let
somebody who isn't
qualified get that license and so we
have to go to these subject men there's
there's no escaping it we are
interlocked and I I think that really
needs to be highlighted how much we rely
on each other and this
isn't I I just want to put that out
there right that that is our goal
bringing around full circle I don't
think you need that section because I I
don't see that as being a hindrance in
any way I don't think that the insurance
companies it's a robust enough system I
think the insurance companies are
looking for Li insure they're not
looking for anything else so I think
from my perspective
um I think we've covered everything we
were looking to do I'm um I'm really
heartened and gentlemen thank you really
so much um that I think that having
having the veterans agency sort of be
the the first focal point and if
someone's struggling to get through this
process that you guys can provide them
both actual uh emotional support and the
whole thing to get through the process
so I I'm really heartened by that i'
just like to say that this is 60 years
too
late I I I never mind we can talk
after I love I'm feeling pretty good
because this is day one for me so I mean
if it's 62 years 60 years too late and
we're getting it done right now I'm
doing I'm doing pretty well so I'm
feeling good about that I love doc doc
Doc's the best guy on the team all right
guys um so I think we've got a good
working order so I will let the
subcommittee know now I'll be scheduling
a subcommittee meeting Wednesday morning
at 9:00 a.m. because we're going to have
to go over the finalized amendments for
the stuff that we're looking at today
and give our approval to it before exec
session starts so just to heads up when
Wednesday 9:00 a.m. we'll be looking at
the finalized copies and hopefully we
can come to an agreement on it and push
it forward to the full committee would
you like us to come back for that um if
you're concerned about like if you've
seen the amendment ahead of time and
you're good with it your absence will
communicate to me that you're good with
it there won't be any surprises yeah
there should there really shouldn't be
any surprises I don't know I've seen
some of the stuff that comes out of oplc
and some of it's 120 pages long with all
kinds totally get 198 page omnist Bill
coming your way
all right I'm going to close the uh
close the session uh we got lunch until
1 o'clock and hopefully some of you are
still here because I need at least three
people huh what are we doing this
afternoon um 11:35 and 14 or
11:58
11:31 and I think it's 1358 maybe I
don't remember I've got to
look this one was
1385 it's posted outside I don't
remember
we
have we have a Corum right yeah we do uh
yes so we're looking at bill um 1413 and
Bill
1131 if you have those no um do you have
them you're GNA pull up 1413 and
11:31
um I don't have any extra copies they're
really simple if you want to sit here I
can share
always commense
[Laughter]
legislation um let's do uh because I
think it's probably the easier of the
two let's do 1413
first wow representative GRE if you
would care to join us at the table that
would be
fantastic that's
weird that it no so 1413 just repeals a
section it's pretty easy and um we're
we're mostly going to be focusing on
I'll turn it sideway so it's
bigger on the this section
here okay so 14 1413 if you could just
walk us briefly through what you're
trying to accomplish with it that'd be
great uh believe it or not I'm still
trying to pull it up by apolog that's
fine we're not in a hurry and Carol is
on her way and okay the more you delay
probably the safer for me okay that's
good
um okay so
14 I'm ready if you're ready if not we
can I'm ready okay so
the what I presented actually redacted
the entire section because when first um
posing what I thought was going to be a
quick fix to the office of lure they
actually wanted the entire section
redacted they were going to put
something in um requesting that because
they think it's duplicative after
listening to the
hearing I actually
um I actually think maybe it was going
to do things that I didn't intend it to
or where they were saying that well when
you take this section out it kicks it
back to the regulations on conditional
licensing which I agree with but I
certainly don't want to put anything
into legislation that's going to be
confusing or that's going to seem like
we're trying to take shortcuts when it
comes to licensing because that's not it
so the big the big thing that what I
started with was there's an older part
in this where it says that the
supervisor um must assume both
professional and legal responsibility
now this is back from like around 1980
so almost every one of these whether it
be social work all these used to say and
legal all of that language has been
removed except for on this one the
complicating factor is with you know a
litigant um heavy Society is that saying
that you're legally responsible for
another adult is a complication so I
just wanted to remove and legal um and
if there's a better way to do that that
would be great but you know the the
problem is we can say it's hard to get
supervisors there are literally um
private practices that are having a hard
time getting supervisors because they
see this and legally responsible well
that means if I'm legally responsible
for somebody I'm supervising they go out
and get a car accident somewhere else
and it's not specified then I'm legally
responsible then too so I think think
it's a little bit of a Miss as our
language has evolved so that's that's
what I'm posing now we can either look
at redacting that entire section if you
guys think that that's the way to or we
can just look at that particular problem
thing that was bottlenecking part of our
uh super
supervisors okay yeah I mean I think
with both of these bills we're running
into perhaps a similar problem where it
may actually be the
interpretation of the medical uh
psychological profession um that's
causing the problems more than any true
legality issue U where anybody's
actually going to pursue that kind of
legal action but I know we've talked
already but for the subcommittee um my
recommendation for this because the the
only thing that they seem to be really
concerned about is that these
supervisors wouldn't be legally
responsible for things that happen
outside of the practice was to just take
the language from actually 11:31 the
bottom of it um
and just say that they're only
responsible they assume the professional
ethical and legal responsibility for
such mental health services so they're
only they're only on the hook when
they're providing the actual mental
health um services and I think that that
would probably I think that's fair and I
think it also makes it um uh
complimentary in the two different areas
that we're not contradicting each other
that it's keeping it pretty similar
consistent yes representative
Gard thank you chair maybe I'm missing
something if you're only when you're
actually providing the services if
somebody was to receive advice from
the professional and then go do
something is that considered you know
I'm trying to get at what point does it
become does it not become during the
service do you follow what I'm saying if
somebody was give them advice and they
go do something can they say well that
guy told you know does it make any sense
or I'm totally missing him morph on this
oh I think I think that is the I mean
you might be able to shed some light I'm
not saying it's your area of specialty
because it's not um no I think that's
the point is you're providing the
service is advice and you know that's
what I'm saying if you if you said go do
this go shoot your mom that'll solve the
problem you're G to be liable for
telling them to go shoot their mom if
you say hey you've got to work this out
with your mom and they go and shoot your
mom then you know the the
psychotherapist isn't going to be on the
hook for that they never said to do
anything of the sort that was the
interpretation so I'm assuming that in
there lies the the differentiation but
by saying while they're providing the
medical services you should you are
liable for that if you do harm you're
liable for the harm that you do and so
that's where the Judiciary would come
into into effect but at a c there is no
record of any of this I mean there's no
record of a um partitioner telling their
client anything it's all done in
confidence right so wouldn't this this
is just
a I mean it's no point even anyway okay
I'll sit back I think I think what this
does too is it it arrow and from just
saying like um you know I I'm legally
responsible you know just in general
which could mean anything once you're
legally responsible like I'm your
supervisor so I'm legally responsible
for you well that's that's a big thing
now I'm legally responsible for you when
you're in the workplace and you're doing
the things that are within your scope of
practice then that's that's kind of
narrow that's like a medical malpractice
versus just being legally responsible uh
so Define drug like if they prescribe
drugs and the
drugs the prescription's terrible and
the person dies or that might be an is
an instance where they would be held
liable for their medal their malpractice
because some of them can I believe in
some instances do that and in the
supervis in the supervisor agreements
they're signing this so they're signing
like yes I'll be responsible or yes so
yeah you know so then so then so the
problem is some of them are not wanting
they're stopping and going wait a second
I don't want to sign this if it says I'm
legally responsible for somebody and
that's it you know because then that you
know unfortunately the way that some
things get twisted and stuff sometimes
somebody could say well you're legally
responsible period because I mean there
are people that get injured and you know
of course the reaction is to go after
everybody that they can depending on how
big that grievance is so it's just
protecting the people that are signing
on to be supervisors and narrowing it to
what they are specifically
supervising anything
else anybody
else that seems like it's pretty much
the whole thing on this one if nobody
else has any thoughts on it is just
changing it so that instead of it saying
that they're legally responsible that
they would be um that they would be
responsible they're assuming the
responsibility for the professional
ethical and legal responsibility uh for
such Mental Health Services we would
just be putting that in to clarify what
they're responsible for does that make
sense
I agree and it's already are you
comfortable Jason or are you
uncomfortable with
this I'm personally not a fan of
Licensing in general so but
yeah licensing is theft is that what
you're saying
yeah uh hello welcome so sry first no
that's okay so um we were just looking
at
1413 sorry I got a frog in my throat all
of a sudden um and going back to 330a
22b here the only real concern that they
had was this idea that the supervisor
would be legally responsible because
they thought the term was Broad and
might go past scope of
practice so my recommendation was to
just take the language at the end of um
330 a34 they assumed the professional
ethical and legal responsibility for
such mental health services so they're
only responsible and I think that pretty
much cleans that one up your thoughts
I I agree that that it's I don't want to
take that section out because I I
actually worked on it to make sure the
um supervisory agreements were agreeable
to all and so um yes so it would leave
everything in place it would just
clarify that one point does that sound
good I'm good okay so now for the mor
fund one which is why I asked Doug to be
here even though it's outside his scope
of
expertise um
so HB
um why don't you tell us
again why this bill was brought forward
and then we can have a discussion on
it that's okay the first one only took
us 10 minutes so you're like way ahead
of
schedule
you're
fine so this one all sorry okay so this
one is so
currently uh the Dilemma is is that when
um people are currently under their
internship so when they're in school and
they're completing that they're able to
actually intern at an outpatient Private
Practice which makes sense they have the
supervisor and all that you know that
that's fine now the issue is right now
with the way that this
reads um once they are waiting on their
when they have just their conditional
license so they're waiting on their
permanent licensing yeah technically
there's no conditional license involved
though they're just they're an
unlicensed person un so when they're
unlicensed but they're still they are
still able to work currently at an
institution so what they what stops
though is them not being able able to
continue so they've been interning in an
out patient private practice that is
allowed by law but once they graduate
and they're waiting on that licensing
even though they could still be under
supervisor right now they can only work
at a state institution or facility and
so we're just adding out patient Private
Practice we're not taking away the
supervisor or anything we're just
allowing that Continuum of Care because
they can have you know upwards of a 100
patients that all o that all of a sudden
sorry I talk with my hands too much that
are all of a sudden um not able to
receive that care so it's it's just
really helping with that Continuum and
more of U housekeeping so I have a
question yes yes that's fine from the
testimony on
143 I got the impression sorry that
a someone who just
graduates can go to work for
a nonprofit Clinic
immediately
and be but cannot go to work for private
organization until that private
organization has a supervisory agreement
specific to um that person in place and
I'm and why the discrepancy that was the
that was why I hoped you would get
somebody here here I've I've been knee
deep in this for a couple days now and
and we just had a lot of fun over lunch
break actually I talk to Lindsay um
here's the problem with this section of
law nothing's
defined so if you're looking for the
definition of any of these terms in
statute you will not find them so it's
wide open to interpretation institution
is not defined facility is not defined
and and to be fair outpatient private
practice is also not defined if we add
that in and clinical supervision is not
defined um so I was talking to director
Courtney on the phone and ironically she
just had was having a conversation with
somebody um who was running into this
situation where the chair of the board
um had told her that she couldn't
practice because she was in an
outpatient situation and had to wait for
her lure to come through and uh director
Courtney went down the same rabbit hole
that I did which was trying to figure
out where in law it says that you can't
and we can't find one we don't think
that this proc includes outpatient
private practicing from continuing care
because they still have
supervision so what we're considering
doing is defining the terms in this
section to cover the people who need to
be covered specifically so that when you
go back and ask the question what is
facility it covers outpatient Private
Practice in its definition so that it
includes everyone and there isn't any
discrepancy my concern with just adding
outpat and private practice into this
section is the vagueness of everything
else is still in place and in fact we're
adding vagueness by adding outpatient
Private Practice because what is that
technically and then we're going to have
this other group of people so what the
board what the chair of the board was
did not do is point to anything other
than this piece of law RSA 330
a34 to indicate that this individual
could not continue to serve at the
outpatient Private Practice Clinic and
and be legal so yes one
one concern that I
have is that this allows an a totally
unlicensed person to work under the
general supervision of the staff but a
conditionally licensed person apparently
needs a specific supervisory agreement
approved by the board yes and that
appears to me to be a disconnect yes I
agree so so what what's what's a good
way to fix that
disp that's that's what the discussion
is and hey it's a pullback on licensing
so it's right up your alley hop in um
yeah no no and and we were having that
discussion as well um I don't know if
you guys would feel comfortable sitting
next to each other um but uh yes so the
the goal is as Mr osterhout put it at
lunchtime you've got ABC and d and they
all basically are doing the same thing
but we're creating an exemption for a b
and c but not D that's what we're trying
to get away from so that everybody who's
working within the same scope of
practice has the same freedoms the same
opportunities um none of them are
unfairly restricted um so yes and that
was also part of the conversation so um
my request uh to oplc has been already
and I was going to run it by the
subcommittee as well but since you're
here you can chime in um to come up with
with definitions that work to close all
of those loopholes so that we
can put all of those people under one
umbrella and they're all operating by
the same
guidelines I think that's fantastic
thank you for your work on that yeah
because that showed up when we at the
hearing for 1413 when it appeared that
most of the testimony was irrelevant to
this the
bill I mean we were sympathetic but
didn't okay didn't pertain um so yeah so
we're in this kind of strange and this
why I said it was going to be an
interesting conversation we're kind of
in this strange realm where you're
saying you need this change because
otherwise they can't do it and both oplc
and at least me um agree that I don't
think this this says that they can't
well I think if I could explain that
where that came from so there are a few
private practices that are very
conscientious and also with with their
insurance um looking at that that their
malpractice is going wait a second so
this is something that I think would be
very helpful to be more defined because
especially when you have you know
anytime you're in the the medical field
you know the malpractice and your
insurance is so specific and you have to
be so careful so I think these are
situations where people maybe are being
overly conscientious but for good reason
I think there have been issues that have
come up so yeah well and and that's what
we've been trying to get to the to the
bottom of and we have not been able to
find anything in rule or St statute
outside of this and so I think that the
confusion came as to where this idea
came from and we can't figure out where
the idea came from so if you were to go
ask the the chair of the board which is
somebody that you would typically go to
to ask the question whether or not this
is a problem that person would say that
this is a problem but we can't figure
out why they're saying that this is a
problem and that's where this is getting
a little confusing Mr user would you
like to share anything I I I don't
remember if I forgot something that you
remember I don't know what you left for
me to say I think you stole all my
testimony I'm so sorry I feel
terrible I usually like to share and I
guess I wasn't playing nicely um but but
you agree with I agree right I think I
see there you go just the weight of your
testimony behind me is helpful getting
[Laughter]
things uh yeah I think I think I don't I
don't understand where that interpret
coming from because I certainly didn't
read that in the law and the oplc
doesn't read that into the law and if
there's ambiguity I think it's best it's
best um addressed by defining words
rather than keep carving out exceptions
and then to your point we carve out one
more does that now preclude something
else that we didn't foresee let's just
Define it uh get rid of that ambiguity
as much as possible and I think that's
going to be better for everybody yes
chairman aguire I think one thing you
could just say instead of saying
institution facility
Etc say it's an organ an
organization that in that provides these
clinical Mental Health
Services
has
licensed count licens individuals on
staff and provide supervision because
that's you don't really care how that
how it's set up as a not for profit or
for-profit or a hospital Branch or
whatever right it just that it's an
organization that has
licensed people on staff that provide
supervision
to either conditional lenses or um
unlicensed
individuals that makes sense to me
because that I don't know quite how You'
say that but that that's the point is
that the yeah those organizations do
have licensed people on staff right
thoughts
Mr I I think that's a policy decision
right and then if you want me to define
words we can work on definitions and if
you think this I wrote down the key
components the organization licens
people on staff and supervision we can
play around with that language too and
see if we can make it
simpler absolutely any other thoughts
from the
committee no
okay I I think the goal is right like
you mentioned is to level the playing
field level the playing field and we
don't have different classes of people
here but we're treating them like we do
yeah and that's that's the problem
wherever the confusion came from yeah so
my only other concern is what you
brought up which is um once you start
adding in supervisory agreements which
is a little bit different but then you
don't have the institution behind it you
don't have the organization ation behind
it um which that's going to affect a lot
of the rest of 330a because a lot of the
rest of 33a deals with supervisory
agreements so this is an exemption from
in part the supervisory agreements and
the intention is that that is to
be the individuals who are who would
qualify for a conditional license that
is they've been trained but they are
not through their residency as it were
and I've been informed by director
Courtney that in this specific instance
there isn't really a conditional license
it's just a two-year permanent license
really wait a minute we just it's called
a conditional license but it's really a
it's kind of a unique license type in
and of itself where you need the
supervision while you complete your
hours so the term conditional is really
there because it's not permanent but it
is a two-year license it's conditional
on
them they can work but if they don't
complete their their supervisory hours
by the end of the
license they're in trouble and
eventually you should graduate to
permanent licensure full LIC the idea
that's just what she said I don't know
you can call it whatever you like
whatever it
is tempor by the end of this day
temporary license conditional license
Perman it's
just just mix it up and pull one out I
don't know temporary it's conditional or
um oh no this was this was a
conversation from the last yeah yeah no
no no that's fine that was totally for
Doug mostly yeah I I had Brad look up
the history on this and this was not
really discussed and since it was 30
years ago 25 to 30 years ago there's
nobody around that remembers
right okay well unless anybody has
something else to um to add I think that
that's the D I mean that makes sense to
me that would probably be the easiest
way to go is just to create the just
clarification clarification yeah do you
want us to do the organization licensed
people on staff supervision route or the
defining well if we do that I think we
just remove institution facility from it
altoe and then maybe we'll have to
Define what clinical supervision is
because I think that the I think the
idea behind clinical supervision is that
the organization itself has supervision
has supervisors it's not a it's not a
supervis supervisory agreement it's not
a one-on-one it's a you might have
multiple people under one supervisor um
so I think usually do yeah so I think
that we'll want to Define clinical
supervision and then I think you're
good I think that solves it I hope thank
you all so much I really appreciate your
work on this and I see how thorough it
was you're so good 25 minutes told you
thank you all though I really do
appreciate you it was better that you
were here though I appreciate it well
that's I was the one who who listened to
the T and then decided that we needed to
consolidate these to or consider them
together right do it all right so this
one you got you got a nice simple
Amendment on that yeah it should be
pretty
easy and I'll work with Doug to get an
amendment for uh
1311 11:31 11:31
perfect okay thank you so
much thank you for uh for having done so
much of the
work yeah yeah yeah that that did help
all right I'm gonna close the work
session then and thank you guys so much
for your time I really appreciate it and
uh we'll see you Wednesday uh so uh we
will have a subcommittee meeting
Wednesday morning at 9:00 A.M because
we're going to have to vote on the
Amendments that are coming for this
stuff the committee is meeting I think
at 10 at 10: but we're going to meet at
we're going to meet at 9: and I will
need people there because they'll be
voting so if you can that would be
helpful if not let me know so I can
replace you on the other hand
take that's
fair